[Music]
[Music]
we'll look man I gotta tell you so we
started huh are we up yeah we're
definitely starting dude one of my
favorite shirts that you have when my
favorite five rotating shirts that you
have Thank You Man pretty fantastic
hitter that's that spencer's hitter
always one or two bottom there you go
this ain't cotton to I think is it I
like a nice poly blend really yeah
Cobra alright your fabric Oh dog you
whatever girl [ __ ] cuz I love you like
a poly blend yeah like that soft hitter
row dude I like that now if we're
talking a Polynesian blend okay I feel
you if you reference some cat then I'm
in because cat is more of that
Polynesian blend
yes your 100% cotton yeah and that's not
a racial thing either man when you right
you right you right
Milana blend yeah dude she got that Oz
she got that lilo and stitch bro that's
how they put the fabric together the
stitch lilo and loom not a new dance the
lilo and stitch dude that should be
coming here what is it then you do that
then this thing you look like the gayest
dude who's landing a plane broke
please baggage handler lax yapper
Spearman's but you thought it was esprit
member that company back in the day
Esprit did they make a closer tanks they
made a horrible clothes there it was
basically just coming out of the closet
athletic wear yeah
remember that company yeah I do they're
out of business bra for a reason yeah
that shirt looks like it's a spree man
this shirt yeah this shirt brings all
the pachyderms to the yard you know what
I'm sayin yeah remember that Jam
Rodentia dog to the what was that
milkshake springing up the boy so young
that was kilo what was that girl's name
oh look at the culture corner yam chant
at six five running from Dallas Texas
douse em same thing first of all you
know somebody's an illegal alien when
they say they're from Central more the
middle part of Texas
oh yeah just you know over by the fence
generalize you have like if he were max
eating like the Undertaker he's like the
tallest why are all Mexican men and
women the same exact height dude five
six five six Stan baby Stan and great
cardio no diet do the damn thing and the
whole bodies all connected same parts
dude no I'm saying the shoulder bones
connected to you toe bone you know yeah
they do look exact and all of the same
facial hair yeah your race is rough no
no all right we weren't all right dude I
got to tell you so uh this couple came
out I had a show in Las Vegas
it's been a while it had been nasty oh
here we go uh huh so Cabo San Lucas
that's where Ezekiel Elliott I just read
an article that's where he's been for
like his whole hold out he said working
out with Marshall Faulk by working out
you mean busting nuts drinking
margaritas that's all they said he's
actually there with Marshall Faulk I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm all my players out
there working out on the Bistro I don't
give a [ __ ] dude okay guys we are
martial brother guys out there just
playing crash in his career dude I'll
tell you this bro
Cabo San Lucas the absolute worst
vacation destination the worst hands
down everything looks like they just put
it together there's smoke like all the
clubs have that crazy the smoke
projectors like just firing smoke into
the dance floor you know and they don't
know that like some people don't want
that right like you'll be in a
restaurant like an Italian restaurant
them you're like in nice clothes and
also and everyone's sick with chlamydia
a zero quit giving us [ __ ]
quesadillas at every place Senor frog's
with the slide out the back the place is
a thirst cab trap Ebro and no people
were afraid to go into the club like one
lady was like trying to walk into the
club like this so much smoke so much
like laser lights bro dude day there was
one guy who was in the dance floor he'd
been in there for two months couldn't
find his couldn't get out makes sense
though yeah hydrated he was just laying
there just barely beating up the beat
brother with the curly straw just lost
47 pounds he said I was like dude you
gotta get out of here he's like nod is
it a little more ODB little more uncle
crappy Araya go back later
little more Uncle Kracker I mean Derek
encountered a show in Oroville no idea
how they can see now I could see it all
you're supposed to go cool it's dull
it's a good vein I'm gonna go yeah it's
a great venue but they have a big poster
and they're like next week man uncle
crackers here I've lived in the same
stage yeah dude I was hard Derek at no
idea you look I got no joke like uncle
crackers [ __ ] cousin Bo you look like
nephew saltine dude he had three bang
remember from your Christmas photo
albums of course remember him from your
life hey do you still FaceTime yellow he
did show up to my show though he would
kill me yeah I want to say I sent this
picture speaking of people showing up to
shows do you remember the couple this
couple that came out to my Las Vegas
show same height first of all which I
love and remember her she was dressed as
the mermaid they sent in a relationship
advice my drip my drip and it was for
him and we started ripping on her you
know what like that fresh - no boy she
looked like that uh yeah a carp a carp
bro she was dressed a little mermaid huh
yeah yeah she definitely really was that
little mermaid and some but they can't
do the show they're like look we're
wearing the same thing and it was so
it's pretty dope that she got those
seashell puppies oh yeah bro how were
they walk out were they run away they
play all day in the Sun dude shut the
hermit crab hitters in the finally on my
legs walking around outside of that
lady's apartment bro you know I'm saying
dude lobsters in the back clams in the
front
I guess nephew salty boy like a cool
track
because he's your real uncle she was my
real cracker bro no joke dude you look
like somebody that's like an accountant
at a Claire's boutique do this dude
Cleveland Browns opening season Sunday
no that's my squad eight nine eight nine
eight every year they go [ __ ] 89 well
they had to draw last year yeah the only
thing that had two draws last year to
tie stuff dude oh dude but although you
think you dressed cool you look like you
know the [ __ ] moshpit at a Michael
bublé concert my love is really you know
start a mosh pit at a [ __ ] petting
zoo in this Petsmart bro take it easy
man this [ __ ] is [ __ ] nice bright in
what you're talking about
then you have some twins at your show -
Theo that's the other thing so some
twins I met a couple of twins here's the
image of them twins that married twins
bro well hold up they first over they
lied to you cuz the two male twins huh
don't they're not Tabler twins they had
identify was in a fire something they
had um but they had like hunched in the
nose like bar they said they were twins
enough exact same nose but you guys on
the left there yeah whatever dude that
is what that is well I guess it's not
we're the same people and they're gonna
like the exact same people which ones on
twins but do what do you give like if
your are twins and you marry other twins
something has two hats like doesn't stop
or something yeah they have kids just
just your mom pop
[Laughter]
yeah just pick your parents pop out of
your vagina great-grandpa hop it pop out
yeah what do you give birth to a damn
Care Bear Brown Freddy Krueger to you
like you're a personal trainer for a
[ __ ] Care Bear the least talented
[ __ ] Billy Ray Cyrus kid I look like
Sugar Ray Cyrus bro dude you look like
you look like somebody that's a you look
like somebody that's a DJ at a [ __ ]
Tim Hortons
which is basically a Hardee's in Canada
it's a Dunkin Donuts in Canada you're
just beaten it miss mix and be no one's
listening yeah well there's a [ __ ]
sausage biscuit in a microwave I'd be in
a senior from shot it down hey Mexico in
general just kidding
my girls makes you yeah I mean my kids
half Mexican I can say what I say build
the wall don't build it that high bro
you know what I'm saying because what we
really want in America is athletic uns
brother we want the most athletic
Mexicans we can get dude because here's
what's gonna happen hardest ones bro so
build as tall as you can but leave some
equipment on the other figure it out let
them work for it oh yeah well dude let
them work for it if you get over the
wall bro that's true you're right here's
an ad from the king of the state dude
when you're selling online getting your
orders out can be a real pain a lot of
time it's expensive lot of tape - dude
so now I get that thing of tape and I'm
like I don't even know what's going on
dude one time I was doing trying to
package a shirt up tape both my hands
together dude I feel you
yeah it's exhausting man and I'm like
how do I make him the best choice well
now I know how am I
lap again you know I'm going to live
life so but yeah what you need really is
shipstation
dude you're so right I know it's the
fastest and it's the easiest and most
affordable way to manage and ship your
orders thing about having an order now
think about somebody else having it how
do you make it happen
ship station ship station helps you get
orders out quickly save money on
shipping costs and keep your customers
super happy
oh man I'm doing great you look happy
what was no that was a customer said
that oh okay yeah ship station works
with all the major carriers including
USPS FedEx UPS Amazon Fulfillment DMV
BRB SPCA - no wonder ship station the
number one choice of online sellers you
ship more and less time with the best
rates possible yep it's the number one
choice and right now King and the sting
listeners can try ship station free for
60 days that's a lifetime if you only
live for two months that's a lifetime
when you use promo code K ATS there's no
risk and start your free trial without
even entering your credit card info just
visit ship station calm click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
type in cat ka TS that ship station calm
promo code cat's ship station calm
cats k 80s make ship happen make ship
happen going to pay to be ste oh dude
dude you're on your phone you're
hoarding food I knew you're doing it
dude you better be using the one and
only you better use the one only
postmates oh do don't you need red wine
at 4 p.m. not you but maybe I do know I
needed you but yes yesterday I got some
candies look I was I wanted to watch a
film at that sweet tooth well I got a
film I found and finally found my VHS
recorder ok you know because my DVD
systems been down because there's an
electrical issue yeah now that makes
sense man and good thing post mates
those that are delivered on time with
under an hour right post matches your
personal food delivery grocery delivery
whatever kind of delivery service you
need all year round whatever you're
craving you do wants Laffy Taffy oh
here's mates that's what they delivered
I ordered a candy aisle I just wanted
some candy is some sweet yeah next thing
you know this boys stopped over to sugar
boy and he dropped off ice cream snacks
peanut butter cups this
that taffy dude at one point he just
took his hand out of his pocket and put
some sugar in my mouth
interesting man I don't know if that's
post mates might want to look into that
24 hours a day 365 days a year
post Knights will bring you whatever you
need within an hour no more trips to the
store hang out in your underwear watch
fun movies or does all the food you want
download the app for your freakin iPhone
Android Android for free browse local
restaurants businesses and track your
delivery in real time and it was push
mates I just looked as marauder was the
guy's name who brought it dude and tip
them tip and well man cuz they're
working hard and right now postmates has
given you guys $100 of free delivery
credit for your first seven days and 15%
and I don't mean I think he smelled like
weed honestly but still it doesn't
matter the snacks were good and the
candy was good and also got some rocky
road ice cream boy and it melted or a
bit fresh I mean he'd had a little but I
had the rest okay dude well I'll tell
you what they want exactly what they get
dude and whatever they want they get
that's post mates download post Mason
save with code k 80s to zero one nine oh
damn I'm good at this anything you need
anytime you need it post mates it praise
Christ time to buy few more pants yo
deal you know September's national life
insurance Awareness Month no idea that's
happening I didn't either who does let's
be huh you do any of that I don't know
what's and I might be driving down the
road worried I'm gonna crash some day
you know yeah I could easily see that
deal with some of the [ __ ] cars you
know life insurance that one thing looks
like a children's play pin that you're
driving around yeah it's called a
Ferrari
that's why 40% of Americans don't have
life insurance dude cuz they're like me
you don't think you're gonna be the guy
that dies yes you know dad no 100
especially dude when you're driving
something that grimace used to drive oh
look I know exactly what you're saying
man you've got to get a policy but cuz
think about somebody that cares about
you that you love and think about them
being poor you don't want that to occur
I'm on the streets no and doesn't need
to be difficult or expensive right now
prices are the lowest they've been in 20
years paying that policy genius has made
it even easier to get you covered policy
genius is the easy way to shop for life
insurance online you
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers to find your best price
possible yep now my first life insurance
policy is that the Lord you know that
but after that policy genius is the easy
way to shop for life insurance sometimes
the Lord doesn't give you the money you
need to love the Lord ain't on line or
you can't get a hold of one of the
representatives he's busy I get a busy
signal so I gotta figure something out
so I get a policy genius a team will
handle all the paperwork and red tape
once you apply if you need life
insurance but you just haven't gotten
around to it national life insurance
awareness month is a good time to start
yep go to policy genius.com get quotes
and apply in minutes you can do the
whole thing on your phone right now take
care of yourself even after you're gone
policy genius the easy way to compare
and buy life insurance support the
podcast let's kick this off day first we
got aren't chrissy i just want to
acknowledge how disappointed chin is to
be here yeah I look over everyone's
laughing I look over and Chin's like
this
yeah chin how does it feel to be back in
the culture corner man let's ask you to
start it could chin did I hey did found
her feels good feels good to be back
it's been a while I missed you guys hey
do you guys have shirts though how you
guys not gonna wear your shirt yeah
culture corner shirts on yeah man oh
there you go maybe next week
way to go guys culture corner well chin
seems very excited to be here
unbelievable bro his blood pressure for
over 635 her rate of a lizard heart rate
of he has the same heart rate of a leave
changing colors in the fall very like
caterpillar all right what do we got D
we got Chris she is 31 years old
apparently the scariest [ __ ] I've ever
met
she used to box box e she was the only
girl on football team in high school oh
one of tho yes one of those yeah
everyday let's just say look she was the
only girl that could kick a field goal
hey icebox what we did is let you kick
it through the uprights here and there
so you could say you're part of the team
now
but let's get back to reality let's go
Derrick what hello she had to walk to
school every day because she got kicked
off the bus for breaking a guy's nose
with a saxophone and once she was in a
car crash and broke both her legs and
her ankles and was joking around with
the cops while the bones were sticking
out of her skin so apparently she's
Chuck Norris damn she's ground chuck
norris after that car accident come on
dude Jesus Christmas bro this is one a
year but he's branded one of my buddies
yeah I'm surprised you guys don't have
the same stories all the goddamn time
actually we do see we we look a little
similar probably so she's just
supposedly the the baddest [ __ ] in her
little town huh well she also has
opposable
Dahmer's tights that her legs look fake
though yeah maybe did say she lost her
legs in the car crash she's broke she
was laughing about it but did she put
him back together correctly because the
she might have some sort of she's got a
little Humpty and her Dumpty you know
what I'm saying bro it definitely ain't
gangrene finally man only 60 episodes
don't burn and [ __ ] cracks a good one
yeah yeah let me text some buddies man I
had the over
man just lost nine dollars to your dad
actually is in the pool to do don't make
me call this [ __ ] aunt Krista to beat
your ass seriously what's the over-under
her and feel fighting oh I knew this
girl minus 200
dude all I'm saying about her ground
game is not that good if you broke both
of her [ __ ] legs
um but here's the thing is she laying
down on this picture her standing up lay
it down in this loading yeah that's a
great picture
yeah she's look she looks like a
beautiful young lady she obviously does
ballet and stuff if she has on those
tights I think she'll she can kick a
football not very well but she's still
on the team and it says she I guess she
dates other women it says used to but
used to box yeah I think that counts
since used to box oh she used to box ah
my bad I thought used to like I'm used
to box only girl on her football team
that's also hi reddit that's also how I
read it yeah hit Tyra I was like oh
she's comfortable around it yes yeah he
wants to fight Amanda Nunez is next to
her private areas
I wonder what city shoes from I don't
know also ever wrote this down and
called them private areas obviously has
been a bigot of crimes before damn bro
are you a grandparent you're graham
cracker I wrote it up they're busting it
my girl dog
man lighten up sometimes dude there we
go in your the poor skeet shuttle dude
and now he doesn't work at the comic
store anymore she has more time off I
bet you're going I bet when he came oh
my babe I stopped my job she's like
better get this mouth ready okay but
she's like a beautiful lady in on and
thank you for submitting her yeah Chris
I'd love to see fight that Chris yeah I
bet I would probably lose to her well
what's gonna be a better fight Dustin
Poirier vriska b-but aunt Chris for
steel Vaughn I don't know man waivers
could be good fight Chris both good
fight choking you out Deeb is definitely
that he's like a bearded strong white
Roach bro you know he's just so [ __ ]
I mean brought you roaches or [ __ ]
over
yeah but roaches they you do you step on
a roach bro its back the next name it's
like six pounds heavier I feel like what
happened use an IV this roach did I beat
up uh roaches look at you like they know
they're gonna be alive in the future and
you're not yeah you're right they've
been around forever uh yes we have aunt
Sandra thought well God speaking of peds
what's up song yeah yeah
oh no it's Bill Maher that's cool damn
that is Bill Malloy's Bill Maher dude
he's getting he got jacked check out the
tits on Bill don't hate that stupid cuz
bill hates women - I don't you know
anything about building oh he hates
white women yeah he loves black women
unless they're really young dude his
last girlfriend was 19 years old so if
you are just past puberty but this lady
has definitely a very Andy Dick type of
just dick sort of vibe going how many
rings do you think she won is that Pat
Riley dude put a couple cigarettes in
her jaw you know who that is that's the
lady that coach Tennessee - 700 wins you
right roll over other lesbians yeah you
right cut that he ready for that Dyke
haircut what's your name sumit Pat
Summitt sum it up bro yeah some
it up I'll sum it up brother let's be
honest uh ah very strong no ox actually
also very strong hard work to make a
good hard-working lady her neck looks
like my nutsack I'm just commenting on
what you put in front of me what do you
mean your vocal cords in your nuts you
know I mean I got wrinkles oh you gotta
iron your nuts out there you right I
need that Botox on my nutsack oh dude
check out the decision what do you mean
shout out to her and there's no roof
drop what do you guys think let's get
Asian let's go fall right man who's a
bodybuilder I can't I swear to God I do
shoot she's uh Miss Universe I swear to
God - what universe dude name three
universes I bet you came what do you
guys think of this let's get Asian over
here huh I feel like if she was in the
Vietnam War America would have wanted
Iraq there would be no Isis he
definitely has that [ __ ] GI Janice
vibe you know that GI James definitely
and she's got GI genetics - dude she's
obviously on some performer they make me
so mad bro she for me [ __ ] hey you are
meme row now I'll say this she seemed
like a wonderful lady she's hard working
hard work dude she's out there her arms
aren't that long and so I know it's she
didn't single yeah Jim what do you think
about she's divorced also oh uh you know
she kind of reminds me I mean it's gonna
be mean I think I was know I'm talking
about
look she's a UFC fighter oh yeah Holly
Holm yes you're gonna say it remind you
of like Mickey gall or some [ __ ] no no
like no not mickey Oh Mickey girl's much
better-looking in this way Mickey Rourke
yeah
yeah micki mustard whoever that is - I
don't ask for this stuff did she send
this to us brother this is a human
person that's alive in the world right
now yeah you write with a lot of
testosterone in her [ __ ] veins and
it's easy to get guns these days I don't
need this heat I don't need to see what
cities did now I got a higher security
bring back the beautiful lady in the
wheelchair that was the first one dude
don't stand up for the picture dude how
that was that car accident icebox for us
bring back big Krista and Christy
whatever her name was Christie chris
Christie Chris I'll show do this ladies
a lot of hard work yeah we already said
that four times okay no I will take it
from here she seemed like obviously
she's good she's at the gym cuz she's
doing stuff it's daytime you can see the
light coming in the windows in the bags
I mean yeah she's getting out there
during the day and taking care of
herself her tits are strong strong Oh
she'll breastfeed [ __ ] yogurt break
I'm saying breastfeed some cottage
cheese and she's breastfeeding milk dude
it's got cereal in it bro with some
kriti relax you [ __ ] kratom addict and
you know Craddock kratom is a Schedule
one narcotic you know I know and I love
it and your son keeps emailing me
telling me you're on it daddy kratom and
then choose me crying a man shot this
lady a lot of hard work to get there
Josh Brolin goes to the gym every day
that's true actually and she seems like
one of those ladies that would do the
pommel horse remember that she looks
like she spent a lot of time on the
cables the chest cables the pommel horse
Oh where they just did it yeah what's
that don't make a face contest those
little gymnasts are Jack
yeah central about four seven but still
oh dude they'll piss brisk and they're
so full of muscle bro don't piss brisket
up next boys a little debate club up
first this is buck Sampson from Michigan
it's buck praise God
what I feel whatever Brendon buck
Sampson here great got a bakery wood
coasters through pop-tarts well me all
that pretty CH I'm noticing everybody
looks a ramble Prince doodle like he was
honestly afraid to admit it
first buddies they're gonna clown I'm
sitting in pop charts of toasters
watching this now like what the [ __ ] can
Asians have so early in the morning
let's go to this culture corner what
about just pop-tarts in general yeah
or can you guys process sugar what's
that like for you guys yep we can
process sugar can't process alcohol Wow
Dairy right yeah Dairy - booked up dude
what Corrine's don't give a [ __ ] though
no still trains the power through ow
I've never seen you do dairy though chin
I use all the time Wow I bring in like
little craft slices and what do you do
just go hard after you eat it or what do
you do where you eat it in the open no
I'm serious you do my car maybe Oh what
are you a little embarrassed around
other yes he's eating it in his car do
you know embarrassed around another
Korean people eat dairy I mean if I mean
dairy something happens afterwards
that's why oh damn my garden I mean a
lot of gas okay - Bruce gas that's why
they can't have you be farting that's
who he's saying so it's body reacted
yeah well they're learning I thought
you're saying something mentally happens
to you or something oh no I just turns
into a [ __ ] Jekyll and Hyde from
cheese well I'm saying if I picture a
tall Korean guy eating cheese quietly in
the backseat of his car you don't think
it's the whole I think something's
happening here okay
I agree I think I don't assume he's
[ __ ] dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde over
here does it make you angry chin
not makes me happy Oh what you happy for
Oh interesting
he's like a sharp charge huh I like it
like cheddar regular you like like a
real sharp sharp you like a violent Brie
that sounds good actually yeah oh yeah
like a prickly parmesan Parmesan is
great you like a [ __ ] cancerous
camembert canadaís
I don't either sure you don't but who
[ __ ] with pop-tarts over I grew up on
both these or toaster strudels pop-tarts
flavors you know heated or unheated come
on heated there especially the cinnamon
ones are purified with the maple sugar
on top however I'm a toaster strudel boy
I grew up with toaster strudels and I
used to have such a sugar problem the
icing they used to give you packs was
the latter remember this this what's the
last like you know for all six of them
my fast would [ __ ] put one in the
toaster and I'd use three icings on one
and then my brother had beat me up the
next day oh I got beat up all the time
because of that really by your brother
the accountant the accountant no
computer program with you really yeah my
bad man it's all good dude but dude I
remember when toaster strudels came out
remember it had just been pop-tarts he
just stood around hungry in the kitchen
before school and then suddenly [ __ ]
toaster schools hit America God they
were beautiful they were from France or
something croissants the croissant
filled God with fruit number out hot it
was dude one of my sisters still has a
huge [ __ ] raspberry burn on her
[ __ ] cheeks like a joker she just bit
right into that [ __ ] fresh out the
toaster dude immediately toasted her
mouth no hand interaction we talked
about that raspberry la WA the raspberry
filled with raspberry lava and they took
icy sprinkle on top and I'd do three of
them all I'd bite into every now and I'd
make a sandwich do two
icing in the middle ah my brother beat
me up my brother had whipped my ass and
you know what I knew he's gonna beat me
up and I still did it Wow
that's how addictive sugar I was I could
see that man they are and they
they were really just a beautiful treat
when they first hit the scene man there
was nothing like a mess hit the blue box
with the little white guy Paul writes
the first box god damn it
that's America they're back that they
let you Owen the ISIS knows I would draw
like a smiley face on there why not or
draw a knife why not I know why not bro
or draw a piece of cheese on there like
chin would do I can just eat that the
imaginary dairy dude that reaches you
come out with a new product imaginary
dairy Chen's lactose treat and it's just
little lactose you use it's like little
C here's a thing too now that I don't
know how they still make them now
everyone's like Oh [ __ ]
health-conscious shut the [ __ ] up yeah
and people said if you had two of them
use gay that's what they say my brother
used to draw a dick and with the icing
on my shoe store yeah I was gay dude if
you eat two of those right you guys uh
it's still worth it to me you know still
worth it that's how good they were
do you remember the croissant would get
around your mouth a little bit cuz it
was so enticing it was so flakier stick
to your mouth I didn't to him like looks
like I'm sucking dick today oh why dude
I think could we just talk about food
well you're the one that said if you
truly turn gay I'm please go back to
Brock Samson first of all a real
gentleman who had to step outside of the
house here on his front porch to admit
that he don't mind a little toaster
strudel your real man he went Pop Tart
toaster strudels he's a man's man and
you can see a deer right behind him
listen and they got that bucks head
behind a week tell that deer still alive
it's gone buck bucks in the front bucks
I'm toaster strudel all goddamn day
that's my childhood you know what I'm
gonna go but I love them it's too sweet
for me it was too sweet for me I'm gonna
still on the stick of pop-tarts with no
frosting and I'll see y'all in heaven
bro or hell no frosty yeah it was he a
six feet under [ __ ] 59% are with Theo
on the pop tart apple our opinion brah
that's what it's called popular opinion
Jesus Christ robe you don't know what
things are knock knock who's there an
advertisement yo abro transformation an
important part of our lives and careers
were always evolving grown which makes
life interesting we're not still growing
dude i mean i'm probably 6 foot how old
are you I think 6 9 yeah I think you
just don't know what growing are we
growing yeah I mean if you are bro than
you are on HGH
yeah maybe our sponsors for this segment
it's story good career transformation
maybe you're growing taller like me and
you'll be my new ball or not visually by
design your new homepage on Wix this is
a cool competition we're encouraging the
king of sting listeners to build their
most imaginative creative homepage a
homepage that highlights where your
career journey is unique just like Theo
okay I don't know what Brennan's talking
about but I do want to tell you guys
about this ok I wish I had known about
Wix the greatest website building site
that you can know about right now
yeah it's quick it's easy the
old-fashioned way you gotta call
somebody they're in a dungeon or
something you got to pay to get them
released or whatever they get out and
then they you know choked out some of
your family members and you have no idea
what they was talking about a website
I'm talking about Wix brother ok let's
get back to the competition just go to
wix.com slash go slash cats to start
your own Wix website for free email your
submissions to Wix loves cats at
gmail.com smoke that Wix baby you feel
me no that's wax what I'm talking about
is wixdude here's the thing man if you
don't have a website who gives a [ __ ]
bro get one go to wix.com slash go /k
ats to start your own Wix website for
free and email your submissions because
we got this really fire contest going on
Wix loves K 80s at gmail.com and we have
our first tune let's check out our boy
Joseph Vaquero registration you know
letters work differently than Brendan
thinks they do and it's Joseph our eco
illustration Wow Joseph's homepage real
soon
it's homepage I'll handle the rest of
this Joseph's homepage draws people in
with per
pocket of colors and images ooh what's
that how it makes me want to reach in
this screen and pull up with something
out man hold on dude
I'm talking about Joseph's new bra
weekend right now
oh Jesus bro check out those bananas
floating around the margins of Yosef
homepage you really captured the spirit
of competition bro those bananas you're
driving me crazy I'm going yeah I think
your [ __ ] banana is split daddy what
I'm saying is way to go Joseph you're in
the running bro oh yeah you got a legit
homepage and if you want to learn more
about Yosef the person and see his
portfolio because he's an artist then
you can check it out now if you haven't
submitted your best homepage yet you
have one more week until we pick the
final winner the winner will receive the
Wix business VIP premium plan for one
year and a value of over $400 Wow once
again that's the URL is wix.com slash go
slash cats and submit your best home
page to Wix loves cats at gmail.com oh
you like salsa yes if I do eat banana
someone got to pay for Theo's haircut
dude have you ever noticed you're seeing
her hand a bunch of ads recycling these
days say no one no we're gonna leave ya
used words separately see others of
space between the world have you ever
noticed people are running a bunch of
ads for all sorts of socks here's what
I'm saying is the alphabet called they
want you to take the day off okay quit
abusing it they said one brand of socks
absolutely changed the game do my feet
feel like they're going to Mars every
time I put them into these warm slick
[ __ ] [ __ ] bags and I'm talking about
going [ __ ] back I can do it Bobby he's
in that first bro I'm telling you about
Stan's socks here's the thing I love
Stan's the style did this people pull
pictures they see me the poor picture
ones yeah
they're great John Travolta revolted
when he smelled my [ __ ] feet I'll
tell you that
Samuel Jackson yelled at me look what
I'm saying is pay no attention to the
pretenders okay it's all fake dude it's
all phony man it's all foot phone eNOS
the only brain you need to care about is
one that actually started it all
Stanton oh thank you love Stan sure you
know why people love Stan's come on man
they've been around for a grip the
designs are incredible in fact there's a
reason why the MLB made Stan's the
official sock yeah
all the players be wearing them yep the
official sock of black lives matter dude
Stan's you don't need to be I don't know
if that's true teal I don't know if we
could confirm that it stands I'm taking
a stance as well no I get where you came
up with the idea but I don't know if
they're officially a softness if
Frederick Douglas had anything on his
feet it was Stan's never can't confirm
that either nope definitely can't listen
Stan's does great collabs like the pulp
fiction ones you got Toy Story Kid Cudi
Star Wars Rihanna Marvel the wu-tang
hitters they got it all man any White's
wearing them oh wow oh yeah ever heard
of Caddyshack Harley Davidson
stepbrothers [ __ ] white people
yeah they are there are two brands one
of the movie names you think black guys
drive Harley Davidson this is gone no it
hasn't it's right back on what I'm
saying is this bro show me not to have a
dodging anything you can buy them by the
pay or sign up for a subscription that
that is based on your preference that's
what I did say this and this is totally
ironic from this ad
I bought these Stan's socks probably
three years ago and I have them on just
ironically today and I really like them
yeah you do love them I really don't
want to put anything else on my feet
neither to steal there's a reason Stan's
changed a whipped-cream you feel me I
feel your dog would lay that night with
that lady
cream cheese that brain will [ __ ]
disagree as a cheese ah you have
listening the show to catch that one
that's why I listen to freely gone to
this ad dude this might be in the front
you know I'm saying so the cheese
segment hasn't hit oh you're right
you're stupid uh you guys can get a free
pair of socks of the purchase at Stan's
calm slash cats that Stan's calm slash
cats because if they're not Stan's you
ain't [ __ ] you know what I agree with
this entire someone's got to pay for
Brennan's coffee habit up next we got
hope I'm killing your name buddy but
Metta Boosh Nana yeah Cara clearly from
the Cleveland oh I like that hair bro
may owe me some of that hair god damn
you saw Minaj Bosh from Dubai and Sri
Lankan um I got you a club for you guys
great here I go with the boys or hang
out with your girl but with the girl sex
off the table you know I'm saying not
even them pretty buzz little hitters
Gang Gang buzz buzz and feel if he comes
here boy diamond get the win from that
hump Jitsu guy and you know butabi
help me up I would love to see you I
shouldn't upset humped you - he's
actually pretty good buzz buzz I love
this guy this guy's awesome
mata bouche cool a complete dude this
guy here's the thing what a great
question here's the thing my girl knows
this like we're best friends but we're
not best friends
I have best friends you're just the
closest female friend I have really this
doll for sure dude I'm gonna get some
[ __ ] for this oh yeah I'm gonna let you
hang yourself dude they call her the
Rope maker hey no sex so we're just
chillin I'm gonna you know my boys man I
mean my boys a get a place live together
you know I'm sayin
no brother do you enjoy
we're someone it as fast as we can
dude yeah you're telling me if you're
besides Derek come on but in general
your friend is obviously a kidnap victim
okay
the whole thing's just cooks and cleans
away from the bus and that's at home oh
yeah the 50s Derek litter flapper wings
get outside the [ __ ] apartment open
the window every now and then at least
let her change the channel Derek who I
see buying wd-40 for all the chains that
he's got on his girl all the time this
poor girl live first of all I love you
I'm look at a bush and I hope to see you
soon if I was coming to Dubai broad we
would definitely kick it man
I really appreciate this foreign shout
out and uh and yeah hump Jitsu that is
why I didn't I couldn't pick up what
he's talking about khabib style fighting
Jitsu interesting when he gets on and I
think it's probably got to be hard to
wrestle somebody who also if it's a
tough man feeling like they're humping
you a little bit it makes it a little it
makes easier for you to win a thing but
no I mean look Kobe was amazing
obviously cheering for Dustin Poirier
and uh and he's amazing - bro so
anything can happen that's the thing
they got a fight they did they they're
only one way to find out maybe Saturday
and get the get the pay-per-view by I
think it's gonna be a good one man 11:00
a.m. we're doing a fight companion for
itself use - yeah oh wow it's crazy man
just be at my place I guess but um
anyway so what I'm saying is this dude
I'm gonna verse is that I called him his
name you Fritz's name Boosh did you call
well he just called him you see the
spelling it's only dude is pick someone
maybe you be a sh Y am I gonna bash
device yeah might get a bus might get a
but I'm not gonna wish first of all I'm
not gonna bus you seem like a nice
gentleman and I'm a glad you are doing
well and um and yeah if friend hanging
out with friends or
girl what was it hanging out friends or
your girl but you can't have sex there's
no sex so you'd rather hang out with a
girl or your boy where your girl where
are we watching Dateline what you watch
whatever you want do you and your
friends watch Dateline no it would be
uncomfortable watching my friends yeah I
got a watch just with my girl yeah I
could watch it I can't watch 90-day
fiance with fiance breakdown yeah he
would love that oh yeah I think we're
the only ones that watch it but let's do
it we are not only to watch a dude
billions of people watch it my favorites
the black guy who has the hottest
Russian girl but she just never text him
back I just she's made plans for two
years and keep sent her money and then
he'll be like she sent this video four
months ago and she like what's up baby I
love you and he's at the airport he's
like I still haven't heard from her but
my bags are packed and we're meeting in
Mexico of course you'd show up
first of all also it's about time we get
some of these black guys back for the
Nigerian scams that have been going on
yeah you ain't lying but I will say this
that I think if you're watching a
certain Show Dateline 90 day fiancé
that's okay Ghost Hunters yeah Real
Housewives Orange County if you're
watching a real piece of [ __ ] television
then definitely you want to do that with
your old lady yeah you're not gonna
judge you yeah my boys a clown if you're
watching [ __ ] The Bachelorette
that's good man so it's only good early
on when it's chaos yeah what's the [ __ ]
out of uh when they got people in their
name like lavender yeah like yeah they
have like uh and they they have to pass
certain mount of black people and you
know the the girls not into black people
it's so strange to me man oh and they do
it like that we want to just yeah but I
think someone's you don't know if it
especially these days but I think I just
don't know did you see when it was the
black girls the Bachelorette and so as a
bunch of black dudes she's faking them
though and they're playing basketball
and that's they're playing like a pickup
game to win a date with her and homeboys
married and his wife he comes in the gym
you've never seen that one ah dude she's
like you're married
he's like dang am i bad girl ball check
Bob from The Bachelorette if I could
real loving hip-hop real quick
ABC's like anyway so girl or guys boy
like I said depends what you're doing
right yeah and I think that yeah
yum yum earning uh that you would love
to see when I get over there at Abu
Dhabi in the future further for the
window when could be once his read when
he wants to try to get his belt back
I'll come over there Dane doing it there
again yeah
please don't get the belt back they're
doing new I'm just doing the America do
it anywhere that's a [ __ ] place that
people can get to dude I went on the
globe to look to see where it was so
first I go to London I'm like okay I've
been on that flight before I can kind of
see what that's like then if you spin
the globe nineteen times the other
direction
finally with Abu Dhabi pops up you spin
it 17 times nope you're not getting in
it's almost like one of those locks on
your locker in high school it's like you
get a [ __ ] just right dude you just
stand out there just yeah what do you
guys think let's go really let's get our
jet let's get well we know what
charities say well I don't have a girl
right now so Oh ladies in the front
ladies in the mag dead bodies in the
front bodies in the back cheese in the
car chin in the back yeah yeah I'll have
it's my voice to you so you'd rather
hang with the boys no girl now let me
ask you this though Jane it's
hypothetical man this guy's not really
I mean real this is the animation from
Aladdin
hey nobody if you were gonna go eat
Korean barbeque what you do all the time
would you rather be a table full of your
girlfriends or your boys well remember I
told you that if you go with Korean
girls they kind of do everything for you
oh my girlfriends but yeah they do you
do get to sit there and just kind of
sleep even they cook you get sleepy if
you want they cook they porridge shots
it's like Derek's girl Wow that's
Derek's lifestyle bro yeah yeah Derek's
girl or we or the missing person it's a
girl or the [ __ ] living space the sex
slave he keeps his price I know like
it's worse for that girl yeah see
Derek's girl on these wanted posters
before Kat you on Deer Lake you seem
like the type there's a lot of guy
friends uh yeah I have girlfriends too I
think as much as I like hanging out with
my man I got to hang out with my girls
yeah it's my girls cuz when you're with
your significant other they want to have
you make like the most responsible
decisions that's me here's the other
thing there's not much to talk about
there's not much to talk about doing my
girl for a hot minute dude sometimes we
go together like a lukewarm in it now
sometimes you go to do just stare at
each other
it's a staring contest she's winning
yeah no I think that I think what you're
saying is really true CAD that yeah it's
like would you say again I just want to
go and have if I'm trying to have fun I
want to go out with my girls yes I'm
trying to have like a low-key night then
I'll go with my man right it's
interesting yeah it's like you can't be
irresponsible as you said you can't be
irresponsible around like your
significant other especially because my
group of friends are enablers so that's
usually how they get wild cat damn damn
girl I have fun Oh
yeah even Chan turned a little bit of
gin [ __ ] put his cheese away got the
cheese should say go on you like a sharp
cheddar yeah
how many of them look it's can still
only name sharp cheddar I know Jin yeah
but you know Brenda was hoping to pull a
different cheese out of his brain jeez
than you you cannot brush yes I can do
it right now right now I'll go then you
go ready oh he gets to start with here
you go ready Swiss bro i provolone baby
parmesan nobody else dude that's what
I'm saying
parmesan let me see yakety yak pepper
jack sharp cheddar
what was just going we're going serial
killer cheese bro let me go with that
why air boy about that Becky breathe is
that a real thing baby burn his retreat
he's gonna break in that one real trees
nature God dude sometimes I got the
rhythm and sometimes I got the blue
cheese
[Applause]
he's good and he's bad because I'm
[Laughter]
[ __ ] what's over that mile chatter
that sweet red chatter I got chatters
all day wrong sweet red chat that's
that's real that's real that's real I
buy it just from England it's a sweet
better foods dude right there sweet red
oh no no that's a type of cheddar I
promise protection it the company's
called
something else oh you scroll in sweet
red LLC right now scroll in or something
like that
somerdale sweet red cheddar suck this
real cheese though yeah that's all I buy
it's another cheddar though it's about a
different type if we had to go the
judges I don't know guys let's go to the
cheese Chinese over here what are we
doing raising somebody let me alone how
about Asiago [ __ ] cheese Mulligan
this is a type of cheese I've just given
out for when you're still [ __ ] food
meat red touch a cheese that's a [ __ ]
hookers a nickname brah
that's a real cheese bro you don't need
your cheese I'll see I'll go for the win
that's your mom calling you give you
more ideas no it was yellow off ask him
Oh
yellow cheddar yellow give something
dude do a real [ __ ] uh slipped on
some what was that Oh cream cheese
[Applause]
[Music]
is that a real cheese
okay I mean that's the thing man it's
like we getting you know is it a real
cheese brie cheese that counts that's
behind uh I don't know if it does but is
it a just a style of cheese you know we
kind of know our cheese's though don't
we ah I don't know I can't remember if
you said this one or not
let's play it that bad mother mozzarella
bro oh did we played that one Davey or
not I don't think and I got an announcer
now I'm going are you
I got that [ __ ] Oh string cheese
string cheese it's a band okay [ __ ] what
it is type of cheese that's all I know
that string hey let's move on Doug did
no minutes go over gene you did on your
ass to go with sweet rag from England
bro
chin you like a sharp cheddar check that
[ __ ] out what else we got d 64% of
people said hang with her boys
we just gotta want to go with a girl or
boy I don't know how you got the chief
but that's we hopefully have a night of
the way all right boys they will go to
relationship advice mix don't come at me
with that cheesy hidden land nothing bro
you [ __ ] it this was that string
cheese [ __ ] bomb of the ninth two
outs
swish stringing a Miss bro that ain't no
that's a shape of cheese okay I can't do
you started just yelling out colors blue
cheese black cheese red cheese what else
Jesus you sweet red
first of all Jimmy red that [ __ ] is
phantom up that's a company no it's not
Kraft cheese no Kraft cheese Robert
Kraft handjobs floor what's this dude
wine dawg okay this is Weston guys this
is Weston coming for some relationship
ending after the hotel what's up guys I
need some relationship advice gang bro
I'm serious at least though you have
here what do you do when you have a
great personality you can get any girl
you want will tell you these monkey
assault yeah that's a car seat in the
back don't worry no no babies are in it
what do you do when you're trying to get
a girl and you can get on with your
president holiday your looks when you're
wearing a hat mmm as soon as you take
that hat off game gank buzz buzz brother
game getting bald bald you know I'm
saying it's tough no that's totally most
dudes don't count that's a style for
them white people it is an affliction
not good not good it's not good
let's just be real it's not good when
you're bald yeah so old it's like our
diabetes whoo I'm saying though
absolutely it's like a Mel like it's
like something it's frowned upon
well milling around and if it happens
it's like very very frowned it's just
alarming it's like always milling in the
distance I mean if you got wing
it's very frowned upon yeah in the white
community but I think well I think first
of all if you seem like an athletic guy
if you're like athletic goes better with
ball than not athletic Amazon he's not
athletic
he looks good billionaire ball but he
also had to be a billionaire to get any
[ __ ] puss probably you know a you
know a $25,000 year Jeff Bezos dude you
just said just internet troll yeah I'm
saying in a Chrysler 300 and I'm not mad
at the wig game these days we go to a
restaurant the student has a fantastic
wig and it's it's a way to you know
conversation started yeah and also
here's one thing that I thought about I
thought about coming out with some new
wigs because it's also like a fad that's
been gone for so long that it's almost
due for a resurgence you know I was
watching some crime show yesterday or
something some lady had a wig dude and I
was like oh hell yeah bro but listen all
but most black girls wear wigs and
they're Joe yeah Michael yeah that's a
good point you'll see a body wax
oh dude Armand there's one lady had a
[ __ ] champagne glass in you know for
sure
and it was like built into the style you
know I saw one with Sirius Radio in
their hair it's great one lady had a
router
I remember [ __ ] getting white of a
signal wireless router I've seen her
around Santa Monica the other thing is
though I didn't know all black girls
wear wave because there's this pretty
black girls don't wear wigs
well if they have like long hair a lot
of them have extensions or legs a lot
but this one girl came in she liked dope
red hair next day she had green I was
like damn just spent all night dyeing
her hair so I think what goes good with
a with a girl is confidence you got to
have that confidence so I'd love to see
some nice toupees on a man we see a man
here locally I'd have it to pay on it
dead he was gonna [ __ ] we laugh we laugh
in that's not home to my guy you can't
tell the other we laugh dude that's not
the part no I'm saying he laughs we
laugh because he knows he's killing it
he's like and it's so obvious he'll show
up and that [ __ ] is just he'll what's
up one day he had it put in a little
shark fin at the top and I love that
because you could take on a dance floor
and be that kind of shark on the dance
floor
you know people tip their hats he tipped
his toupee to us who went how you doing
boys oh there it is
there I think it one thing is you use it
as a motivation tool to safes to stay
physically fit because having no hair on
your head is but being physically fit I
think that kind of matches your gonna
sexy it's kind of sexy right secondarily
UFC logo yeah your head looks okay bro
dude if I lose my air bro I am never
gonna work again bro yeah totally flat
on the top yeah it's just gonna get real
awkward in a couple years you know and
your Lego piece yeah I'm gonna look like
a [ __ ] leg
Lego might need to work on camera let go
of your bank account no but but with
this dude also you could do the LeBron
James spray paint that [ __ ] look like a
Pittsburgh Steeler you know I'm saying
also the other thing you can do is you
can just kind of go the Professor X
route good wheelchair
get real skinny I think there's
different styles that you like just
spitting ideas out here I'm Ser chin has
low hair or no hair I don't even know
China are you going bald buddy
as though is it for sure but do you feel
uncomfortable cuz I feel like this look
fit to you do you feel uncomfortable I
like it when it's short now I can when
it's long so well pay for that dude if
you can grow facial hair I think a ball
looks good
but here's the thing you see is the the
bird's nest on the side like an old man
ditch that yeah I'll have it all shaved
drop that nice little be that beard
hitter look like Zack brown bear and
start [ __ ] girls down dude
who else is losing hair in here no you
losing some couldn't get any more hairy
Derek your shits get a little thin in it
black guys it's a tight style yeah and
Derek yeah and also darica will have
long hair sometimes he doesn't really
your hair doesn't really seem like it
does it if you said if do you think
about your hair like I can still grow it
out long but do you think about it a lot
like does it no that doesn't bother me
there's my four hams and does it do you
for hims I've never thought about it ah
man
okay let it go you're growing up heads
your attitude now that's a good attitude
guys aren't like that but here's the
thing you don't have to worry about his
girl cuz she's blindfolded yeah so now
you look good you're good
yeah she definitely not I'm gonna let
you go today
but I love it but now one thing I'll say
is this though a lot of it is your
attitude towards it as well because it's
but interesting because zoom in I
started noticed my hair is getting thin
in the front and the top is thick
pro-roh but I noticed it right so then
in my mind it starts getting to be a
bigger thing and then I start getting
paranoid I start wearing hats I start
like you know talking to people and look
another direction I start doing things
that seem obtuse for humans damn yeah
yeah dude I'm not joking I know dude
doing this movie training thing I was
like oh maybe I'll wear a bandana like I
just start thinking of things so then a
lot of it is odd then I'm fearful my
confidence is going so then it's like
I'm trying to talk to him find in the
bushes you know what I'm saying I'm not
even a peeping tom I'm just a guy who
just has their concern now you're a
catfish yeah now yeah now I'm Nev
Lieberman or whatever that guy's name is
Nev Schulman yeah do you like dope in a
bandana though yeah the small one then
tie it and get the long out the back but
with your dachshund eggs same bro know
it's a bummer with no hair on the top
but you have here on the top I have here
on the top but also then you know
there's surgeries you can get these days
we get some other taking off but for you
I don't know probably do that man I
think I would just get a nice round head
dude yeah I would just [ __ ] rock with
the round head and have confidence try
glasses if you want to try some
different yeah but but also dress nice
but also you got a ditch the side the
bird's nest dude that's number one let
me show it to old and no one no one's
attract that [ __ ] yeah didn't you look
like you're going bald whereas now you
look like you're making more of a choice
like it was like your controller bro
like you control it yeah father times
your barber yeah but you control it dude
yeah get it [ __ ] shave tight to the
side and dude I also just got my hair
cut at a casino in Biloxi Mississippi
other day and had the absolute [ __ ]
worst haircut of my life really cuz you
look exactly the same
really yep thanks man yep all right well
good luck man
oh god boy fantastic good to have you
back man
good to be back I need to take a break
from the Hollywood Life and join the
peasants down here yeah man well it's a
nice down here and now it's good to see
everyone everyone's doing well and nice
to see Jen back to it stay here chin you
know I miss that guy yeah he doesn't
look thrilled but if you just give him a
wheel of cheese I'll be fine
good to see you man huh
got any shows coming up uh yeah I got
some shows they're gonna be something
gonna put a few shows back on the books
that uh and I got some shows in Europe
that are in January now and what else
man I know you were just at that
Oroville casino how was that was fun
dude it was an easy gig fun great great
like it's a cool like kind of concert
set up yeah cracker did it dude also
Taylor Swift did it no way now she was
14 but she was still there that's all
that we care about dude you think Kid
Rock would beat her asked if they were
in a fight or not is that a conversation
I think a good fight I think Oh cracker
beats the [ __ ] a both of them yeah
Bubba Sparxxx though dude
yeah you know we get come on now I met
him oh I've that's what I met in a bath
on your old pop what the People's Champ
I met him at a bathroom in New Orleans
one time yeah nice and it was hard to
talk to him cuz somebody press that
[ __ ] hand dryer what an [ __ ] oh did
you see I'm trying to talk to Paul Wall
God whoa how much time do I get with
Paul Wally hyoeun he was and I even it
was like Paul wall wall dryer and it was
like a bad joke and it was this [ __ ]
awkward and then he just walked out
Jamie she got some fronts from them and
some sizzurp e-cell sizzurp on the side
too oh yeah dude I'm going
she's not my diamonds have his breath
smelled like dimetapp make sense
robitussin I'm going to Paul Wall town
and you soon September 20th 21st Big D
coming with me Doug ultra culture oh
damn I love that dude well cheese and
pride are gonna perform with me
somewhere then Oh perfect dude that'll
be funny yeah we're gonna have a cheese
meetup even Derek being Houston with
Paul Wall drinking scissor band get some
grills I'll hashtag very dairy for our
next stop you know
if you guys come on out come on out all
right I mean uh pass I'm at the ice
house September 12 my oh you Nicole
children will be there yeah if you're in
town let me know dude September 12 ice
house Pasadena that's a Thursday that's
next Thursday and then I'm in Houston
September 20th 21st and then Denver
after that baby hometown end of
September I'm in Denver Comedy Works
downtown I love it and uh good luck so
Dustin for you this weekend good luck
dog
[Music]